[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance we have elected a shitty
businessman amid everything else from
the psychosis to the Orange Bowl in the
nuclear china shop we have elected a guy
who doesn't know the first thing about
the American economy any business that
leaves our country for another country
fires its employees builds a new factory
or plant in the other country and then
thinks it will sell its product back
into the US without retribution or
consequence is wrong there will be
attacks on our soon-to-be strong border
of 35 percent for these companies
wanting to sell their product cars AC
units etc back across the border first
of all that's exactly what he did not do
with the carrier company in Indiana the
thing he is still boasting about as if
instead of a tax break for some rich
guys what he had really done was to give
everybody eternal life carrier got seven
million dollars in taxpayer money from
the state of Indiana to not move eight
hundred jobs to Mexico and it is still
moving 600 jobs to Mexico and it's not
facing a 35% tax for selling its Mexican
made products in the United States
Donald Trump shitty businessman but of
course it's far worse than that consider
for a moment what would really happen if
he really was able to unilaterally and
immediately impose that 35% tax don't
think about the thousands of jobs at the
hundreds of carriers tile companies
around the country right now think about
the jobs as yet uncreated Trump shitty
businessman
is telling companies domestic or
international that if they open new
plants in the US or hire more Americans
in their operations already in the US
there's no going back
those jobs had better be forever if
another company in carrier's position
let's call them merrier hires one new
employee in this country and then
something happens to the economy of the
country or just of the SH merrier
company and they have to fire that one
guy and move his job to Canada or
somewhere suddenly according to the
Trump shitty businessman plan there
could be a 35% tax on all SH merrier
products sold in this country explain to
me the motive now for SH merrier or
anybody else ever to expand their us
business again explain to me the motive
romário or anybody else ever
hire another American worker again add
to that this idiot trump states as if
there were no laws as if there was no
Congress as if there were no courts that
quote there will be a tax like he could
just make one up as and when he wants it
what kind of business wants to invest in
a country where the economy is
predicated not on regulations or even
just patterns but on the whim of one
shitty businessman and as if to
underscore this the Vice president-elect
the one whose home state just bribed
carrier with seven million dollars of
our taxpayer money so Trump can boast
about what a super genius he is Pence
went even further when it comes to
punishing companies that move jobs out
of this country Mike Pence says quote
the president-elect will make those
decisions on a day to day basis again it
ain't his call there's no reason for
Trump to know that he's just a shitty
businessman but Pence has supposedly
been the governor of a state for nearly
four years a state with laws and a
legislature and courts and he has just
told all those businesses that are
considering hiring Americans great but
don't ever try to fire them because if
he's in a bad mood generalissimo shitty
businessman will slap you with a 35
percent tax because a guy who got two
million fewer votes than the other
candidate is convinced he's Moses coming
down the mountain with the goddamn
Commandments in his ads President Elect
shitty businessman has just thrown the
brakes on a huge part of the American
economy and what's worse he may have
also thrown the economy into reverse
there was a second part of that tweet
storm you've missed these companies are
able to move between all 50 states with
no tax or tariffs being charged this is
an even dumber deal not only do our
imaginary executives at SH merrier have
no motive to add jobs in this country
but now with the economy stalled by the
new 35% revenge tax from Donald J Trump
shitty businessman they can say to the
governments of whatever states their
plants are now in if you don't give us
more tax breaks or build us new
facilities we're moving to Wyoming first
you cut the legs off our economy by
any company that expands its workforce
on the logical premise that yes in bad
times it can downsize its workforce but
then with jobs suddenly scarce you give
all employers everywhere an official
sanction to Pit one State against
another hell to pit one County against
another like this was a nation of sports
teams looking for a new taxpayer-funded
stadium the states and communities
willing to bribe companies the most and
with lower standards of living so
employees have to get paid the least
we'll be able to take this country's
economy to the [ __ ] cleaners because
we have just elected a shitty
businessman resist peace